a Florida man has been arrested in
connection with a slew of bomb packages
mailed over the past few days of course
why didn't we think of it first a
Florida man it makes perfect sense as
the mainstream media jumped to blame
Donald Trump
the New York Times buries one very
important detail about the bomber we
will discuss then all of the polls that
matter 12 days out from the midterm
elections why only leftists are allowed
to dress in blackface and the caravan is
on its way
I can hear Honduran gangsters play
finally the mailbag
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael NOLA
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
more bombs more bombs being delivered
they finally got the guy he seems like a
total weirdo as you might imagine we
will analyze and know not only will we
analyze this guy and the bombs and
possible motives we will analyze the
media's reaction to all of it but first
we have got to make a little money honey
I'm here I've got a better five second
stopover in New York on my way I'm gonna
be speaking at Alabama on Monday night
it's gonna be a lot of fun I've had a
lot of fun in Sioux Falls Augustana
University last night I was at Grand
Canyon the night before so because I'm
in New York right now I feel even more
of an urge to make a little money honey
that's why we got to talk about Lending
Club for decades right now credit cards
have been telling us to buy it now pay
for it later and then they charge you
very high interest rates there is a
better way despite your best intentions
I know what can happen the interest
rates can get control of you fast don't
be stupid
take control of that now you can pay off
your credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment Lending Club can help you do
that since 2007 Lending Club has helped
millions of people regain control of
their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to
the bank no high interest credit cards
this is very important for me as a
millennial I hate having to go anywhere
to do anything I just go to Lending Club
com tell them about yourself how much
you want to borrow what terms are right
for you if you're approved your loan is
automatically to positive go to it is
the number one peer-to-peer lending
platform over thirty-five billion
billion with it being loans issued go to
Lending Club comm slash anoles Kanter
wles
check your rate in minutes bar up to 40
grand Lending Club com / Knolls Lending
Club Khan / Knowles all loans made by
web bank member FDIC Equal Housing
lender let's talk about the bombs they
they got this guy they arrested him I
honestly there are more questions than
answers at this point but good job on
law enforcement for tracking him down it
was reported at first that he was a
white man now it is being reported that
he is Native American although as Senate
Rick's Elizabeth lieth of Warren taught
us last week even if you're entirely
white you
can be Native American so we haven't
figured out exactly which it is yet but
the guy seems like a total Looney tune
obviously he's just accused right now
but if it's him he's made bomb threats
before in 2002 he threatened to blow up
the Florida Power & Light Corporation
and said that it would be worse than
9/11 he's apparently not very good at
making bombs he has been arrested many
times before for theft and burglary
so definitely seems like a weirdo there
there are some questions to be raised
here
one one is why none of the bombs worked
none of them I mean this guy I'm glad to
say mirabile dictu is the worst bomb
maker ever it's just not not good at it
he's the worst bomb maker for a few
reasons actually one because he might be
screwing up all of the momentum going to
Republicans in the midterms and he's
screwing up our jobs not mobs narrative
but two none of the bombs worked and
this this does raise some questions
why did none of the bombs work we were
told by law enforcement that they were
all sent through the mail but the images
that we've seen of some of the packages
don't have any mail markings on them
they seem that you know stamps were
placed on them but it doesn't look as
though they were processed by the post
office law enforcement is telling us
that they were but there are a lot of
questions there so there were a few
theories I felt there were four theories
about who was doing this we still don't
really know much about this guy so I
guess all of them are still in play the
most generous theory for the left is
that it's this it's a wacky right winger
who doesn't want to cause actual harm so
when he was found he was found in like
the creepiest van you could ever imagine
and the van had all of these stickers on
it all of these right-wing pro-trump
stickers on it and they were all really
nicely done seemed quite new and it
seemed a little on the nose not to be a
conspiracy theorist or anything but you
just think all right if you want a guy
to seem like a right winger you know
you'd put all of these brand new
stickers like I voted for Trump on it so
I felt that was the most generous to the
to the left and probably though the
that's unlikely that he doesn't want to
cause actual harm I think they're much
more likely scenario which is also
pretty generous to the left in this is
that he's some whacky populist type on
the right or the left
kind of like the Bernie bro who shot up
the Congressional baseball game this guy
would be the trump II version of that
and because all of the people that were
targeted are establishment people the
Clintons Soros Eric Holder John Brennan
you know they weren't going after the
Bernie Sanders side of the of the
Democratic Party they weren't going
after Alexandria Ocasio Cortes so I
could see it you know as a populist type
and that's what the evidence seems to
suggest now then the less generous idea
for the left is that it was some lefty
who wanted to make conservatives look
bad it doesn't seem that that's likely
anymore but who knows again we don't
really know anything about this guy
plausible I think it's still too wild
though and then the most conspiratorial
tinfoil hat theory the most you know the
they're turning the freaking frogs gay
theory is that it's some plot you know
by bureaucrats to undermine President
Trump that also doesn't seem likely and
the reason it doesn't seem likely to put
a damper on some of my more
conspiratorial right-wing friends is
that there were so many states involved
there were so many law enforcement
agencies involved that if it were some
grand conspiracy I I think somebody
would have leaked it or there would have
been some whistleblower so again I don't
think that's that's likely it seemed to
me number two or number three were the
most likely some wacky lefty or that
it's some wacky Trump populist or or
left-wing populist looks like that but
we we did forget the the great
possibility the most obvious answer
somehow we forgot about it which is that
it's a Florida man you know it's always
Florida man it's that guy he must never
sleep Florida man just Flitz about doing
the craziest things including sending
horribly constructed bombs to
politicians and what's weird too about
the bombs is that they had they had a
digital clock on a number of them some
of them apparently weren't even able to
explode
so we'll get to this in a second because
the New York Times even admits this and
buried the lede but just to wrap it up
on Florida man there is a story that
came out last week about these two girls
in Florida an 11 year old and a 12 year
old who were Satanists planning to
murder their classmates and eat them
that's true that's not hyperbolic the
story came out here is quote from the
from the news headline when asked about
motivation the girls reportedly told
police that they were Satan worshippers
according to police the girls planned to
drink their victims blood out of the
Goblet they were found with they also
discussed eating their victims flesh and
leaving body parts at the school's
entrance before killing themselves
Florida man Florida girls these girls
were 11 and 12 Florida man right before
Halloween by the way for anybody out
there who doubts the existence of
personified evil who laughs at people
for believing in the devil or believing
in personified evil how do you explain
that explain twelve-year-old girls who
want to participate in as a tannic
ritual like that a little bit of a
sidebar but Florida man unsurprising so
we don't know a whole lot right now I do
get a kick out of the fact that after
these multiple weeks of Liz Warren the
whitest woman in America pretending to
be an in Native American this suspect
may actually be a Native American like a
real Native American he apparently lists
tribal affiliation in certain documents
so we'll have to see how that plays out
but the one thing I think that we can
all conclude we know it for sure is that
this is Donald Trump's fault right I
think we have to conclude that because
look I've been watching a lot of CNN
I've been in airports a lot this week
and when you're at airports that the
only place that CNN is played in the
entire world is on airport televisions
and they told me it's Trump's fault
because apparently I don't know if you
know this Trump has had a lot of violent
rhetoric he's been very violent in his
rhetoric he's calling for a lot of
violence and have you ever I mean I I
booble didn't I found a video here is
all the violent rhetoric from President
Trump recently
I just don't even know why there aren't
uprisings all over the country maybe
there will be you cannot be civil with a
political party that wants to destroy
what you stand for
terrible get up and please get up in the
face of some Congress people is this the
quote-unquote mob well that's so weird
Donald Trump sounds a lot like Spartacus
doesn't he I've never heard President
Trump sounds so much like tears of Rage
Spartacus oh no wait a minute that
wasn't Donald Trump that was all
Democrats that was all major Democrat
officials including their most recent
presidential nominee calling for
violence nevertheless all were hearing
from the mainstream media is that
President Trump has created a culture of
violence
we'll get in a minute to why that is so
insidious but here is what Donald Trump
is actually saying more broadly there's
much we can do to bring our nation
together for example those engaged in
the political arena must stop treating
political opponents as being morally
defective have to do that the language
of moral condemnation and destructive
routine these are arguments and
disagreements that have to stop
no one should carelessly compare
political opponents to historical
villains which is done often done all
the time got a stop we should not mob
people in public spaces or destroy
public property
[Applause]
he's exactly right it was exactly what
he should have said got it right who
could possibly eject object to it
we know who does CNN in the new york
times object to it we'll get to that in
a second first let's make a little bit
more money honey let's talk about mint
mobile this will actually say to you a
ton of money the big in big wireless
stands for a lot of things big contracts
big bills big fees eighteen just has a
new 800 million dollar administration
fee increase I will tell you I have had
to deal with big wireless companies
before it is the worst experience I
think ever known to man I know is that
an exaggeration I don't think so it's so
bad mint Mobile has figured this out
what big wireless doesn't want you to
know is there's a way to cut your
wireless bill down to just 15 bucks a
month not 15 bucks plus a giant
administrative fee and this fee and that
fee 15 bucks period food to I busted I
sound like I'm Michael avenatti
it's incredible mint mobile cuts it down
that you can use your own phone with any
mint mobile plan you can keep your old
number along with it you choose between
2 5 and 10 gigabyte 4G LTE plans even
try it out mint mobile has you covered
with their 7 day money back guarantee
outfox big wireless you can cut down you
can pay end up paying a fraction of your
old bill this is a incredible plan get
your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month plus free shipping on your new
mint Mobile SIM card go to mint mobile
comm slash cough FA CE o VF e fe mint
mobile comm slash cough fa cut your bill
down to 15 bucks a month get a free
shipping on your mint Mobile SIM card
mint mobile.com slash cough fa ce o-- v
f e fe President Trump is exactly right
here he's exactly right the media have
been equal Regis about all of this first
of all he's right that we should all
come together we should he recently just
gave a statement to just within the last
few moments on how will we have to
prosecute this guy to the fullest extent
of the law we cannot have political
violence take hold in the United States
obviously political violence takes place
on the right and the left it's taking
place a lot more on the Left these days
but you know maybe this guy is a
right-wing or I don't know I I haven't
decided how far
the conspiratorial rabbit hole I want to
go but let's say let's take everything
at face value let's say he's a
registered conservative Republican he
subscribes to the National Review I
don't know he whatever it is let's say
that he is a actual Republican look at
the response from politicians that's
what actually matters here when when the
left was being violent going to
Republicans houses going to assault them
in public at restaurants where they eat
where they sleep how did the Democrat
Party respond they encouraged it all of
them so many of the Maxine Waters
Hillary Clinton Eric Holder Cory Booker
they encouraged the violence when
there's some wacko Republican who sends
poorly made bombs that fortunately
didn't hurt anybody when that happens
how did the Republican leader respond to
that he said we've got to prosecute this
guy to the fullest extent of the law we
can't have any political violence in
America two starkly different responses
you can't control everything
obviously people are going to be wackos
let's say this guy is a registered
hardline conservative Republican who
knows if he is seems more like he's a
wacky criminal Florida man but let's say
that he is fine what really matters is
how the parties are responding to it the
left the mainstream media which is just
the talking the the microphone the
loudspeaker of the Democratic Party
they're encouraging the violence the
conservatives and Republicans are
discouraging the violence and
encouraging prosecuting people who
commit violence absolutely CNN today
before they caught the guy they ran a
headline this is maybe the most
egregious one I've seen in the last week
I don't know CNN always outdoes
themselves week over week take a look at
this clip and just just look at that
chyron we definitely see a pipe shaped
figure in the x-rays we definitely see
wires surrounding and within the devices
themselves a clock that clock could have
been used to actually activate the
device one thing I'm not seeing in the
x-rays and I'm just seeing my x-rays on
so you see that they're a quote ten
packages sent to Trump targets Trump
targets what do they mean they mean
Democrats they were ten packages sent to
Democrats but they say Trump targets is
if Trump is their master mining the bomb
plot that's the implication that's what
they want their viewers to take away
that's plainly what the language says
Trump has targeted these people and now
this guy is sending poorly constructed
bombs to them
that's the employee and that's just a
flat lie and the New York Times
complains when we call them fake news
they say we're an apple or a banana
whatever that stupid whatever that
commercial was that is fake news that's
a lie and it's libel anything that is
that is true calumny against the
president the New York Times was a
little better their headline was just as
egregious but you you got to watch how
the New York Times write so the New York
Times headline on this was quote pipe
bombs sent to Democrats and Trump
critics what we know and don't know yeah
that's true
Trump critics sure they could have just
said pipe bombs sent to Democrats
because all the Democrats are Trump
critics every single one can you name a
Democrat who isn't a drama critic no but
they wanted to get that in there to link
Trump to it at least it's a little
better than CNN but the way the New York
Times writes is they bury the lead they
do it as the structure of the newspaper
they always have the most sensational
propaganda on page one and then they
have all of their corrections on page
1075 but what they do in the articles
too is they bury the lead they have all
their sensationalist propaganda and then
25 paragraphs down they give you the
information so I've skimmed this
ridiculous article and then 25
paragraphs down or wherever it was I
read this quote none of the devices have
detonated leading some officials to
question whether they were designed not
to explode or if they were even capable
of doing so some bomb technicians who
reviewed photos of the device that
circulated on social media on Wednesday
suggested that it resembled the kind of
fake device often portrayed on
television and in movies that's not from
daily wire that's not from some
right-wing web site that's from the New
York Times admitting as much very good
then you know then then they go on and
they say law enforcement
Cheryl's determined all of devices
devices were likely sent through the
mail this does raise questions about why
we didn't see processing on on those
packages but even the New York Times
admits this may have been some sort of a
hoax now what was the motivation of the
hoax was it a hoax to have some
political effect on the midterm
elections was it a hoax to scare
Democrats they easily could have been
that sort of folks we just don't know we
should wait to get those answers but I'm
very pleased that in the reactions to it
broadly speaking conservatives have been
saying have been grounded I said the
other day on the show you've got to
remain calm and remain clear especially
when things get really heated because
when people get emotional when they get
angry when they start jumping to
conclusions they go mad and they make
mistakes don't make mistakes we're 12
days out from an important election so
you've got to stay clear-headed and I'm
glad that the president has has
refrained from being sensationalist
about this he said exactly the right
things and let's hope that conservatives
continue to do that we also have seen
megyn kelly get fired I go away for one
day and the news media falls apart
they're bombs going around the country
megyn kelly former darling of Fox News
got into a spat with the tunnelled Trump
actually during the 2016 election goes
over to NBC for a record contract over
there she's out why is she out she's out
because during a program she asked the
question of whether or not it's okay to
darken your skin in a Halloween costume
to pay tribute to somebody so somebody
on the Real Housewives dressed up like
Diana Ross you know and she darkened her
skin a little bit this caused an uproar
and megyn kelly said well is it really
blackface if you admire the person who
doesn't like Diana Ross it just is it
okay or is it not okay she makes those
comments people pretend to be outraged
nobody's actually outraged people just
pretend to and then she apologizes she
said I didn't realize it would cause
that stir but I see that I was wrong and
then they fire her they can her for
reaction we now turn to NBA Hall of
Famer Karl Malone
sometime at night
call below look up in sky and say what
the hell going on up there
the UFO live on another planet phone and
whole like EP call me Laurie on TV about
white people getting deducted by alien
sticking all kind of hell up they butt
and that's a damn thing now home alone
never see no flying saucer his self but
if he do that's gonna be a spooky time
that's what Tom Lola say government got
to step up and give 102 percent to
keeping them little green man off this
here earth because the day to em dude
stick something up call Malone but
that's gone well Danny ain't gonna be no
good time for nobody
especially call mallow but oh that I'm
sorry that wasn't Carl Malone that was
jimmy kimmel wearing blackface
that was Jimmy Kimmel wearing blackface
specifically to put on a minstrel show
because there it's this is not him
putting on Karl Malone's
skin tone because he's admiring Karl
Malone er talking about what a great guy
Karl Malone is he does it here to make
fun of coral Malone for being stupid and
to make fun of him for speaking in
Ebonics and for speaking inarticulately
the if anything isn't a minstrel show in
modern day minstrel show that is yet so
he does this but Jimmy Kimmel he's the
toast of Hollywood Jimmy Kimmel he's
he's the host of the Oscars Jimmy Kimmel
has a late night show okay now at the
time that was on Comedy Central and what
was it 15 years ago 20 years ago that
that came out so he goes he wears
blackface no reaction whatsoever
including now no reaction but fine you
could say well it was a different time
it was on a comedy channel that was
always provocative and it was a cable
network it's not the same so that's
that's fine I do hear that point for
reaction or for real reaction we turn
now to comedian Chris Rock kind of
questions like imagine anyone how many
guys are cracked and Rick James mostly
recorded super
FreeNAS do you think the only way to get
a brother on the shoulder name it pool
of $50 cash in a pair of Cooper's oh no
wait that wasn't Chris Rock even that
was a Jimmy Fallon wearing blackface
okay Jimmy Fallon on NBC on the network
that just fired megyn kelly for asking
if it's okay to darken your skin for a
Halloween costume if you admire a person
that is Jimmy Fallon wearing blackface
putting on a show doing actually a
pretty good Chris Rock impression and no
problem whatsoever he hosts I believe
the longest-running program in
television history The Tonight Show on
NBC no issue no problem doesn't get
fired it's okay so why was she fired I
don't think she was fired for this
comment she was fired for her poor
ratings for ratings haven't been great
she's being paid record amounts of money
over there at NBC I think they still
over 69 million dollars on her contract
and Eve even that I think doesn't
explain it I think she's being fired
because of her politics not just that
she's a conservative I don't know if
she's really a conservative she's
certainly more conservative than people
at NBC but she's going pretty hard after
NBC during the me to movement and NBC
has had a lot of me to experiences and
certainly Matt Lauer Matt Lauer was the
biggest example of this would lock women
in his in his office and harass them and
she was pretty hard on this she went
pretty hard after them while other
people on that network went very soft on
Matt Lauer I think that's why I think it
poisoned at the relationship between her
and NBC because she wasn't gonna go soft
she's a pretty hard-hitting journalist
she left Fox after a very tense
relationship with Donald Trump and so
she's pretty hard-hitting I don't think
they wanted that I didn't think she was
a good fit over there anyway I think
she's better doing this hard-hitting
journalism and being a prosecutor and
going hard after people I don't think
she should be Katie Couric she's a lot
more interesting than Katie Couric so
she's gone who knows where she'll and
maybe she'll go back to Fox but the
double standard is absurd she asked a
question about blackface and was fired
for it Jimmy Fallon who am I like who I
don't think he should be fired for doing
that sketch
but he actually performed in blackface
and Jimmy Kimmel who's on a different
network but he's still a late night
story he's still the toast of Hollywood
actually put on a minstrel show actually
did blackface in the way that blackface
is described historically actually did
all of that no consequences whatsoever
mmm he thinks politics has something to
do with this so honing in on NBC on over
on MSNBC lawrence O'Donnell listen to
the president Trump's speech the other
day we talked about it on the show where
president from said I am a nationalist I
know you're not supposed to say that
anymore it's not politically correct
I am a nationalist okay we know what
that means he's juxtaposing it with
globalism and he says I'm gonna protect
the rights of Americans to govern
themselves American sovereignty I'm not
a globalist when I say nationalists it
it means I'm not a globalist but
Lawrence O'Donnell on MSNBC he has the
real it he knows what that really means
take it away mr. O'Donnell Trump knows
exactly why you're not supposed to use
that word and that is why exactly why he
is using that word and by telling his
audiences that he knows he's not
supposed to be using that word he is
telling them that he is brave enough and
bold enough to use the word he is brave
enough and bold enough to use a 21st
century variation of the word racist
because he wants Trump voters to know
that he hates the people they hate a
majority of Americans reject all of this
vile trumpism all of it nationalist
apparently means racist to lawrence
O'Donnell because because to the left
anything they don't like is racism
racist racist is just the word that they
substitute for evil they think of them
as synonyms they say oh yeah it's evil
if Trump does it it's evil now of course
this isn't the case moat Moses was a
nationalist nationalism has a long
history we talked to your Mazzoni who
wrote that great book the virtues of
nationalism but that's what they're
saying is saying it's racism it's racism
it's racism they're always playing the
race card I don't think it really works
won the Democrat Party is losing its
hold on racial minorities and too
we're seeing the failure of globalism
hurtling toward us in this migrant
caravan that's coming toward the border
this is a big winning issue for the GOP
and for conservatives let's if we can
can we check in right now on the migrant
Caravan the juxtaposition between that
oh it's just the caravan it's the
caravans painted red and white it's not
it's actually painted with some
criminals it's painted possibly with
people who want to do harm to this
country it's painted with cynical
leftists who are going to exploit our
extremely generous immigration policy
that's what I think whatever I hear this
Caravan I just think like but that's
certainly not what it is it's a horde of
thousands of people invading this
country and we can't deal with it we
don't we don't want them to invade our
country and have their first act in the
country be to violate an important and
essential law this is true of both
parties and so it's a winning issue I
mean I think you know when people start
calling you names when people like
lawrence O'Donnell say that that's
racism that's just racism that's that's
how you know you're onto something
unless it's actually racial bigotry but
obviously this is not that's how you
know you're onto something because
they're saying that's evil that's equal
don't do it don't do it don't do it he
knows that this is a winning issue for
conservatives he knows that this will
get a lot of Americans we don't this
would have been a winning issue for
Democrats ten years ago Barack Obama was
talking about this 12 13 years ago he
was saying we cannot have people come
over illegally
this is why by the way a lot of people I
think are skeptical or were skeptical
about the this bombing campaign of all
the fake bombs that didn't explode or
harm anybody because there
so many issues going so well for
conservatives right now right before the
midterm elections that this really
throws a bizarre wrench into it for
apparently no purpose at all other than
some lunatic criminal Florida man but
this is a big issue you know you've got
jobs not mobs now the Democrats are
gonna turn that into mobs not bombs
I guess mobs are better than bombs but
mobs are not better than bombs if the
bombs don't work so I don't know I have
to do all I have to do the math on that
they also were running on the Cavanaugh
effect and they can also run on this on
this migrant Caravan coming hopefully
that won't be slowed down the momentum
won't be slowed down by this failed
bombing attempt we're gonna have to see
I mean there's a lot of momentum moving
we don't have any new polls obviously
from after the arrest that just happened
a couple hours ago but even in New
Jersey Bob Menendez who had a safe seat
is now being seriously challenged by his
GOP opponent Bob Hugin a Hugin is now
within five points within striking
distance of Menendez and they're the the
Cavanaugh effect is really hurting Bob
Menendez because sure the whole
Cavanaugh premise was we don't need to
know if they're innocent or guilty we
just need to know if enough questions
are asked about somebody's sexual
history that is disqualifying for public
service and I don't know if you follow
the news it's been blacked out from a
lot of mainstream media but there's an
allegation that Bob Menendez paid
underage hookers to have sex with him
and you know he finally got off he
wasn't they weren't able to convict him
of this but I'm sure that when when they
were saying all that matters are the
questions being asked you saw Bob
Menendez sitting in the Senate like well
yeah well okay I'm gonna add guys don't
be over here at the I'm gonna be at the
coffee pod for until you stop talking
about this they're nailing him with
these campaign ads here's one of the one
of the greatest ads of the season
against Bob Menendez the American people
make their judgment not whether the
person's guilty or innocent but whether
the person deserves to have the office
what about the underage girls who
accused Bob Menendez a
according to the FBI not whether he's
innocent or guilty this is not a trial
but ultimately has enough questions be
raised new jersey's Bob Menendez is
being forced to deny allegations of
engaging with prostitutes sex with
underage prostitutes in the Dominican
Republic is he the best we can do
good question senator it's time for Bob
Menendez to go virutal ad absolutely
devastating well done to whoever the ad
maker was we're not going to have good
numbers on this for a few days one the
the arrest of the bomb guy was on a
Friday so you're hitting the end of the
news cycle we don't really know that
much about him I'm sure more is going to
come out over the next few days people
are going to be out of the news over the
weekend people probably aren't going to
be processing this until Monday so
you're probably not going to get
reliable polling information on how this
is going to affect the midterms until I
don't know Tuesday or Wednesday at the
earliest this is a little scary for
Republicans all that matters are the
trend lines when you're when you're
looking at polling it doesn't matter
what the numbers are when you're two
weeks out from the election
it's all about the trend lines because
unless somebody starts sending bombs to
people and it unless that really matters
to voters the trend lines aren't going
to reverse the trend lines were all
going in the GOP direction who knows i I
don't know what's going to happen now if
you'd asked me before they caught this
bomb guy and it looks like he's a
populist right-wing or whatever that
means if he's obviously deranged too and
probably living in a van but before that
happened I would have said everything
it's unstoppable for the Republicans to
to stop this blue wave now I don't know
if the if the trend lines reverse
because of this bomb thing I can't see
them in reversing again it's hard to out
do a dozen fake bombs being sent around
so we're just gonna have to see what
happens with that we've got to get to
the mail bag but first don't miss our
next chapter of another Kingdom
performed by little ol me today it will
be live stream for the first 15 minutes
of episode 4 which is titled worst
homecoming ever then you can listen to
the audio but subscribers to the daily
wire can get another Kingdom on Monday
they get it several days early you get
to watch the whole thing there's super
cool art this year and cool sets so go
on over there you need to subscribe to
because you'll get me you'll get the
interplay
sure you get the Ben Shapiro show you
get asked questions the mailbag which
we're just getting to you get to ask
questions in the conversation you get a
ton of stuff but you also get the
leftist tears tumblr that's not what
this is this is a Grand Canyon
University tumblr I left my leftist ears
tumblr in Los Angeles and I'm almost
drowning they were they were kind enough
to give me this tumblr it was very sweet
of them it's not it's not cutting it
it's not
if this isn't built for a leftist tears
this it can't sustain the high levels of
salt the high acidity of this leftist
dears and even that sweetness you know
it's like I don't know what is that what
is that type of corn that popcorn words
but sweet and salty
that's what leftist tears are like like
kettle corn go to daily wire calm get
yours we'll be right back with the
mailbag from Erin hey Michael I've been
dating this girl for coming up on a year
now and I have to say that objectively
she seems like the kind of girl I should
be proposing to oh here we go where is
this going but I find myself constantly
with the urge to look elsewhere for
female attention because I feel less and
less attracted to her physically I don't
want to be the kind of guy that breaks
up with a girl because she's not the
body type I'm looking for in a way I
think I'm looking for permission
I'm permission to what I have the
permission to break up with her is what
you're saying
I'm 22 if that info is necessary okay
you should break up with her that's the
simple answer you should break up with
her you this is what you I know you
tried to put it in this nice language
what you just said to me is in theory
I'm in love with this girl but in
reality I'm not go for the reality man
you're gonna be married in real life to
your wife and you you should be
physically attracted to her you really
should I got I want to tell any details
out of school you know I don't want to
you know I invite you into my boudoir
enough when I'm selling you purple
mattresses sweet little Elease is a real
looker you know I mean that's a that's a
big deal that's a big deal you're a man
you have red blood you have to be
attracted to your future wife or fiance
or girlfriend you have to be attracted
to her
doesn't mean by the way that she's got
to be a supermodel or she's got to have
one particular body type or this or that
that's not how attraction works you can
you can find yourself extraordinarily
attracted to some aspect of her
personality that maybe overwhelms
physical attributes that you're not as
physically attracted to okay fine that
totally makes sense but there has to be
an attraction you're not starting a
business with somebody that's not all
you're doing at least you know there's
there's one part of marriage where
physical attraction really matters so I
you can ask your parents about that one
so you've got to be physically attracted
to her
that doesn't make you shallow you'll be
physically attracted to someone else and
it's not fair to her like you're pitying
her like you're like if she's a charity
case or something no she sounds like a
great girl I'm sure this she'll meet
some other guy but if you really find
that you're unattractive to her then you
shouldn't marry her now maybe I don't
know maybe you're exaggerating it maybe
it's this I don't know
don't try to plan out your marriage on
paper like you're writing a doctrine
like you're here's my mirror this is
what my marriage is gonna look like
is that great Yiddish expression Mensch
tract boat Locke two-man plans and God
laughs you know Cole Porter didn't sing
let's do it let's be in our relationship
where you have all of these attributes
that I think will go well in a wife he
didn't he said let's do it let's fall in
love that's what you should do you
should fall in love if you haven't
fallen in love find somebody else from
wisly hello to the execrable Michael
Knowles hey wisly great job at politican
I watched both your panels and you did
an amazing job of staying composed when
antagonized I occasionally have
discussions with those on the left and I
have a hard time staying composed when
they fling lies and idiocy my question
is was that always part of your demeanor
or did you have to learn it if the
latter had you go about that I usually
keep my cool I've always been able to
keep my cool just about occasionally
I've lost my temper
that's the Sicilian I think coming out
but from the vast majority of my life
I'm able to keep my cool and this is a
very important trait and it requires
practice and you should do it because
being a man requires being a gentleman
and living in civilized society means
that you need to
civilized so you should always keep your
cool the other question when you're
talking to somebody about politics or
philosophy or theology or whatever is
what's the purpose of the conversation
if I'm on a panel where people are being
antagonistic and it's really sort of a
debate then I'll slam them I'll try to
score points because I'm trying to
demonstrate for an audience why their
view is incorrect and why my view is
correct if I'm sitting down having
coffee and I'm just trying to talk to my
friend and hear his point of view and
and give him my point of view then I
won't slam him to have a different
demeanor in all of those cases though I
am emotionally detaching myself when you
get angry you go mad when you go mad you
get stupid and you behave stupidly and
you make stupid arguments and don't do
that part of the other reason why I keep
my cool is that
as John hight showed a few years ago the
right understands the left much better
than the left understands the right so
I'm not usually surprised by arguments
the people on the Left are making I
think I could probably tell them their
arguments before they could tell me them
themselves the left is surprised by what
the right says because they don't
understand the right so when you tell
arguments to them they don't really
understand them or they haven't thought
about them before and they get very
irate they get very angry about what
they don't understand you should seek to
understand it if you find yourself
getting angry all the time
it might be because you don't understand
their point of view so you should read
up on it I assure you it's wrong but you
should read up on it at least so that
you can tell that yourself and remain
civil you know other people yelling
idiocy at you cannot degrade you only
you can degrade you only you can
compromise your integrity only you can
make yourself look foolish and humiliate
yourself so don't do it always stay
composed always be the bigger guy be
tough be hard bring them a fight but
don't be nasty don't be brutish that
doesn't serve anybody from William
Halloween is upon us
Oh ffred Halloween is upon us and a very
serious question arises are ghosts real
love the execrable show William this is
a very good question and hotly debated
by theologians I tend to believe that
ghosts are real
but I'll give you two fathers of the
church Saint Agustin brought in a guy
who wrote City of God confessions
broadly he rejected the existence of
ghosts st. Thomas Aquinas who wrote the
Summa Theologica
believed that ghosts exist and that they
come you know a ghost is a disembodied
spirit a disembodied soul human beings
are soul and flesh when you die you lose
your flesh and the soul is separated at
the end of time at the end of the age is
that the Second Coming we Christian
theology states that we will be united
our souls in our bodies and the redeemed
will have glorified bodies and things
don't go as well for a thief people who
are damned but before the end of time
can a disembodied spirit or soul come
back and show itself from Scripture
certainly that seems to be the case we
know what the Transfiguration of Christ
he's standing up there with Moses Moses
it wasn't wasn't standing there in his
flesh was he that was a disembodied
spirit we know that angels can manifest
themselves demons can manifest
themselves in Christian theology we see
this so I tend to side with Thomas
Aquinas but I don't go looking for
ghosts also because there are spirits in
this world I know it's very
unfashionable to say that in our
materialist times but there are spirits
there were principalities and powers
there is spiritual wickedness in high
places there is personified evil and
there is personified good and so don't
go looking for ghosts don't go trying to
communicate with the dead and don't go
trying to talk to demons you know that I
mean that that's story about Satanism in
Florida where the 11 and 12 year old
girls are going to murder and eat their
classmates and as a sacrifice to Satan
that should remind you that there is
personified evil in the world
don't go looking for it you know just
keep your eyes up looking at God and do
the right thing and don't be worried
about about where you're going afterward
and watch ever goes from Robert oh no
I'm sorry first question from Lois
Michael knower of all the reasons to
vote blue will you be dressing as Rachel
Maddow for Halloween this year thanks
Lois no I will be wearing a costume for
Halloween this year from Robert
dear marginalized Knowles do you believe
that humans are created to need God if
so do you think this is why doing the
wrong thing without God seems easier
humans are required to need God by
definition we need God you didn't create
yourself this is why libertarians
sometimes go a little wrong in their
ideology you did not create yourself you
are not responsible for the creation of
your life your life is a gift given to
you by your Creator who is God so you do
need God and humans have a longing for
God a natural law at all times in all
cultures throughout all of history we
have a longing for God we have longings
for other things too we have a longing
for food and there's food to eat there
we have a longing for water which is
called thirst and there's water to drink
it's we have a longing for sex and there
are beautiful women walking down the
street everywhere you look so it it
seems unlikely to me that we have a
longing that doesn't find satisfaction
in something which is an argument for
God this is also why doing the wrong
thing is a little bit easier a part of
that is because of the fall because
we're not perfect creatures because we
have freewill and we've used our
freewill to reject God so it's easier in
the short run it's always very tempting
but it doesn't doesn't work out well you
you want to and what we strive to do is
to align our wills to the will of God
but st. Paul writes about this the
things I want to do I don't do the
things that I don't want to do I do
constantly I do frequently and this is
why mankind needs Redemption but we
certainly do need God even if you're
skeptical or doubtful of Christian
orthodoxy or Judaism or any other
religious tradition it is simply a
material fact you didn't create yourself
you need God from James mr. Noles no
matter what Shapiro says I enjoy your
show I need advice I'm running for local
office in a difficult area I live in
Portland Oregon I want to run in local
elections but being under 25 Christian
and Republican basically means I'm
ineligible how do I run for office in a
hostile territory why on earth do you
want to do that why on earth do you want
to subject yourself not just to politics
not just to running for office which is
miserable
not just being an office which is
miserable but to local politics which is
the most vicious of all in an
extraordinarily left-wing place that
antifa is currently running I believe
there antifa is the occupying martial
force now in Portland and why would you
want to do that when you're under 25 you
have a life you've got a life to live
man you can go out you can have fun you
can make money you can talk to girls
what are you doing don't run for office
don't run for office don't do it
I'll give you some advice that I got
from a prominent politician and a member
of the current administration side I
won't say who it is I was driving around
with him in New Hampshire one time and
on a campaign and he turned to me said
you know Michael do you ever do you want
to go into politics and I said well you
know I'm in a car with you in New
Hampshire so what do you think and he
said okay here's my advice don't don't
run for office when you're young don't
run for Congress when you're 25 you'll
ruin your life you'll ruin your family
you won't accomplish anything there and
you'll you'll lose money you'll lose all
your friends don't do it don't do it you
have to ask yourself why are you running
for office is there one particular issue
you want to solve in Portland Oregon
it's there one is there this or is that
or is it just because you have some
political ambition and you want to get
up to a higher office and that seems
like the thing to do if it's the ladder
don't do it there are better ways to
make an impact and there are better ways
to have a life and there are better ways
than to run for office right away and if
you do want to run for office which can
be a noble calling you should do it when
you've got some experience and when you
can do it yourself and you don't have to
dial for dollars and you don't have to
make yourself beholden to a lot of other
interests just my two cents do we have
time for one more I'm doing one more we
don't but I'll do one more anyway from
Patrick Knowles I heard some person
arguing the other day that people who
are pro-life are and are also for the
death penalty or hypocrites how do you
object to this Thanks
hashtag came for Ben's stayed for Noel's
yeah good man
it's a stupid point I don't know how do
I respond to that how do I respond when
people say to me no good I don't respond
to it I say okay yeah that has no no
semantic value we've just conveyed it I
think the confusion among people is from
this slow
pro-life it's a good slogan and it says
broadly what we mean but what we really
mean is that we object to the killing in
the womb of unborn babies without due
process who are utterly innocent we
object to that of course we object to
that there is no there's no refutation
of that objection it's an evil awful
thing that is indefensible
so we object to that they say well but
so you support punishing criminals yes I
support punishing criminals us you think
that the state has the ability has the
right to punish criminals yes of course
that's the definition of government or
that's the definition of a justice
system well okay you can punish them but
should they shouldn't be able to kill
them should they why is it okay for the
state to take someone's entire life away
keep them in prison for 60 years behind
bars and solitary confinement but it's
not okay to kill them if anything death
is a far more just and merciful
punishment than life imprisonment or
life in solitary confinement or
something like that
the latter actually is cruel and unusual
at the time of the ratification of our
Constitution the punishment for a felony
was hanging was death that was virtually
the definition of a felony everyone had
capital punishment nothing unusual about
it keeping somebody in prison for 50
years that you know thirty years
whatever the sentences that is unusual
and I do find it cruel I think it's much
harder to make the case for that than to
make the case for the death penalty
there are three different kinds of
punishment punitive punishment a
rehabilitative rehabilitative punishment
you know therapeutic trying to
reintegrate them into society and a
deterrent punishment to try to deter
other people in society from committing
that crime right now we only focus on
rehabilitation and we say it's the we're
gonna rehabilitate these criminals okay
that's it that's fine but also justice
demands punitive punishment and it
demands deterrent punishment to protect
the rest of society all of which are
accomplished with with capital
punishment including rehabilitation
because it focuses the mind precisely
when you know you're to hang it probably
changes your point of view and where
you're looking and what you're
prioritizing in your life so there's no
there's no contradiction whatsoever and
I think the confusion comes from that
slogan which is ninety-eight percent
correct but you can clear it up by
explaining precisely why you object to
killing unborn babies in the womb
innocent of any crime without due
process shouldn't take too long to
explain that okay that's our show I'm
going to Alabama on Monday and we're
gonna have a very cool speech
I haven't spoken about this topic
publicly until this tour and it is how
to write nothing and sell 100,000 copies
it should be a very fun speech so check
it out on Monday but we'll have a show
before then in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you them
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua Elvira the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you